[Music]
[Applause]
Prime Minister Harper thank you so much
for joining us today thanks for having
me
before we begin could I please get a
quick show of hands from all the
Canadians in the audience raise your
hands
oh wow oh and all Canadian campus here
who would have known you've clearly got
some pull around here mr. prime minister
we've had many topics to discuss today
from your views on key policy issues to
moments of leadership on the world stage
before we start the I wanted to start
with a very simple question is it true
that despite writing a book about
Canadian hockey you don't have a
favorite hockey team no that's not true
I I never was very clear in public as to
what my favorite team was because I
always felt that I could lose more votes
on answering that question than I
seriously so my my we actually have two
favorite teams in our household the
Toronto Maple Leaves I grew up in
Toronto my father was a maple eat fan
and then of course as an adult I've
resided most of my adult life in Calgary
so we have the Toronto Maple Leafs and
the east and the Calgary Flames in the
West but since Canada isn't won the
Stanley Cup since 1993 I will take any
one of them anyway desperate at this
point clearly judging by this year's
performances at the Olympics there is a
lot to admire about Canadian sport so
take that now I wanted to shift to your
beginnings as a politician back when
they were still in the Union University
what originally drew you to politics
well it's a it's a long question it's a
long answer I first of all I never in my
university days I never intended to be a
politician that was not the plan to the
extent I had a plan that
not the plan I was interested in
politics because as a very it started as
a as a kid from the time I was about
nine years old my parents expected me to
read the front page of the newspaper and
to be conversant in public issues at the
dinner table so I kind of started that
interest early on university I was
studying economics I became very
interested in public policy and my
interest then and my first job in
politics was as a as a researcher and
that was kind of how I saw myself was
essentially a research assistant and I
had longer-term plans to become an
economist and to be involved in public
policy in academia so that was really
the beginning of it and it's a lot of
steps that led me to where I was and and
I'd love to get to some of those steps
yeah we talked a lot about
entrepreneurship here at the GSB and
your political career shows many signs
of being very entrepreneurial
especially when you United the different
right leaning parties within Canada
under one banner in 2003 could you talk
a little bit about how you managed to
pull off that difficult task and why you
were the right person for the job well
let me maybe just go through how I ended
up in the job because I have the most
unusual path to the prime ministership
of anyone in Canadian history the only
one to come up through a third party so
I went to Ottawa in 1985 as a research
assistant an economics graduate to
assist the government on its program of
deficit reduction and market reforms and
some of the other things that we
believed in left that job after a year
I'd only intended to be there two years
maximum but left after one year fairly
disillusioned with what the government
was not doing on these matters I was
convinced that would never balance the
budget in fact that turned out to be the
case so I actually not only left the job
actually left the party went back to
university to do graduate degree and in
the course of the graduate degree I
people heard me talking about my
experiences and a number of professors
who had similar thinking hooked me up
with a felony and press the Manning it
was
forming a new political party to push
some of these issues much harder called
eventually called the Reform Party so I
got involved in that in 1987 I became
the first policy chief of the party I
did it this is actually true I remember
saying to the then president who became
eventually a colleague in Parliament and
ministerial colleague I remember saying
to her she asked me why I was doing this
I said well I sort of like what they're
doing here and this is a fun hobby it's
not going to take much of my time
anyway one thing led to another in the
first time we ran for election the
election was suddenly upon us we had
almost no candidates so I became a
candidate obviously didn't win we didn't
win any seats but I did surprisingly
well and then the next time around I
decided to run again when we had a much
better shot and I ran and got elected in
1993 by the end of my first term look
I'd say there's no plan here by the end
of my first term I could also see that
the Reform Party as I had envisioned it
was was kind of stalled and once again I
decided it was time for me to do
something different I went and had a day
essentially conservative political
action committee in Canada so I left I
did not run for re-election and I did
that for three or four years and I was
about to depart that job into a true
private sector job when the party that I
had left the Reform Party which had
converted itself into something called
the reform conservative alliance when it
had a massive civil war in the party
around leadership and it was so bad that
the party sunk to the low single digits
and support was almost ready to drop off
the map and virtually everybody of some
node in the party was discredited by the
civil war and since I was not there I
was the only person of any stature in
the party who wasn't tainted by the
civil war and a lot of the MPs
approached me would you come and lead us
and we just paid off the mortgage and I
said to my wife you know if I do this
wasn't what I was thinking of it all if
I do this I'm gonna become leader of the
Opposition without trying like I will
win this race if I get in so
got in she agreed I got in I won the
race and then the other conservative
party had a massive civil war and we
were it wasn't going well we were all
looking at oblivion and one thing led to
another
both our parties were ready to do a
merger we both understood that if we
stayed separate our chances of not just
winning our chances of survival were
limited so people really did it in some
ways out of desperation the timing was
just right partly because my background
was a mixed partisan background I was a
kind of a good person to lead that
effort I had a good partner on the other
side named Peter MacKay and we United
the parties and then the next thing that
happened was the then governing Liberal
Party was so certain that it couldn't
possibly lose an election that it
engaged in its own Civil War and I ended
up leaving the leading in the next two
elections the party was united and they
led the party that was divided and in
politics the guy United usually wins it
sounds like it pays to be the last man
standing yeah yeah I do have an
interesting story on that it's funny
after the last election a cup I had two
or three colleagues you know I'd stayed
in Parliament a while and some former
colleagues visited me and I did point
out to them
I remember saying first time it
surprised me but I tried it again I said
you know I am the only member of
parliament from the great revolution of
1993 the only one of the Class of 93
still in Parliament I'm the the last man
standing who would have believed it and
every one of them said to me we always
thought that was what was going to
happen so they saw it before I did well
it's good to be a rock in the storm if
you will you you are also known within
Canada for positioning yourself as a
progressive conservative when you ran
for election in 2006 what I wanted to
ask you next was how did you decide
which sacrifices you would make in order
to govern and which principles you would
not compromise yeah look I would not
have described myself as a progressive
conservative part of it part of the
issue in Canada is that is the name of
one of the two founding parties so that
would have identified you with one party
rather than the other look I I consider
myself a straight conservative I'm
conservative on most issues I'm not
concerned I'm conservative probably more
in the temperamental than the
ideological sense and I'm a strong
believer I get this is where we're
people consider it modern moderate I'm a
strong believer in incrementalism in
policy and I think some describe my
government as kind of a series of what
they listen incrementalism in terms of
the steps we took across ranges of
public policy
partly because not that sometimes you
have to do radical departures but
sometimes but but generally speaking I'm
distrustful of you know frankly smart
people like ourselves with great
blueprint prints that we're gonna kind
of invent the solutions to the world I
actually think you have to see how
things work what unintended consequences
are whether something is turning out as
you expect before he moves it to the
next step so I tend to be someone who
wants to gather data and see what the
experience is until I take the next step
when it comes to gathering data
incremental ISM and and dealing with
very weighty policy issues one that's
that's very relevant today and where
Canada gets a lot of claims immigration
and President Trump has cited Canada as
an example that the US should
potentially follow and you've never
known to support skilled immigration in
Canada what lessons incremental or
otherwise could US policymakers learn
from Canada's example well look I'd say
two things and I'd say this not just to
American audiences but audiences
everywhere else I mean what I think was
most remarkable for other political
leaders about our immigration policy was
not that for the most part they were
successful policies in the policy sense
it's that we had overwhelming public
support behind our immigration policy
behind a large-scale immigration policy
how do you do that first of all on the
success side
we were progressively moving our system
towards being based on labor market
needs on responding to labor market
needs the first there had always been a
significant portion of the Canadian
unlike the United States always a
significant portion of Canadian
immigration policy that was admitted on
the basis of skills and labour force
considerations we vastly increased that
over time from you know forty percent
two-thirds we started by making it was
really a simple change but it worked
wonders was allowing University students
to find work in their areas while they
were in Canada which would often
encourage those students to stay once
they graduated a really simple change
made a big difference in policy so I'm a
strong strong believer that immigration
policy in the modern age must be based
to be beneficial for an economy must be
made based on labor force needs and
requirements it doesn't mean you can't
have humanitarian and family
reunification streams but that is not in
my mind the central benefit of an
immigration policy for one's own country
the second thing no one let me say this
because I'm in the United States you
know I'm often asked in the United
States or Europe you know how can we
make our current immigration system more
popular why is it so unpopular well I'll
tell you this right now if Canada had a
huge percentage of as you do in the
United States or Europe a huge
percentage of its immigrant population
was here illegally or irregularly
outside the law it would not be popular
illegal immigration is not popular
anywhere in the world at any time and if
you want to sustain public support for
an immigration system this has to be a
decision the society takes through its
laws and it forces the law and unless
you can fix that problem and I think
that is the big problem United States
without a solution to that problem
people's resistance to legal immigration
has gone through the roof and you know
my quick comment on the United States
the big problem you have here is way too
difficult for someone to become a legal
immigrant and way too easy for them to
become any
there seems to be also a flipside to
what you're saying when it comes to
public support which is in addition to
upholding the law there is this embrace
of multiculturalism in Canada yeah that
that seems very unique and distinctly
Canadian and so what I wanted to follow
up with with is in an age of rising
nationalism Canada has this unique
position and you know it seems to be
both multicultural and patriotic and I'm
curious do you think that this is a
blueprint for other nations to follow
that you can be both things and if yes
how can we encourage both yeah look I
think absolutely first of all I think
Canada had a bit of a traditional
advantage on that from other countries
and that you know Canada has never had
one clearly defined national culture and
we've always had at least we've had two
national languages we've always had at
least going back to major religions and
obviously it's more diverse today so
there was never a kind of a unified
vision of what a Canadian looked like so
I think that background kind of helped
but on multiculturalism we actually
modified the multiculturalism policy
somewhat along the lines really of how
its practiced in Quebec and technically
in Quebec they don't call it
multiculturalism they call it anticucho
that Eastman which interculturalism
doesn't mean anything in English but
what it really is is it is about
encouraging I would say promoting is not
the word but encouraging immigrants to
retain aspects of their identity their
links to their home country their
traditions but encouraging that within
the concept of a broader social unity
and a broader participation and we as a
government really saw multiculturalism
well it had the obviously the the aspect
of preserving people's native and a
diverse set of cultures really it's an
objective was ultimately integration
stems from the belief and I do believe
this strong
that first and foremost immigrants when
they come to a new country they want to
belong they actually don't want to be
get away they may want to retain aspects
of their personal and family identities
but they want to belong and so you know
we encourage that but at the same time
would recognize that as you diversify
the ethnic and religious mix of your
country that inevitably there will have
that will have some impact on the
mainstream of your own culture so that
was really the philosophy behind the
policy and and you know we think it's
look I think it's objectively successful
Canada has few kind of ethnic based
deeply ethnic based conflicts it's it's
a very diverse society where people
integrate reasonably well and this is
going back decades and from my
standpoint we are you know the
Conservative Party of Canada is one of
the few center-right parties in the
world that wins a large share and in
case of 2011 an outright majority of
immigrant vote yeah it's a it's a
powerful set of options future
policymakers please take note but I'd
love to build on this notion of
belonging but now on the international
stage you're a passionate free trader
you under your watch Canada signed
landmark free trade deals with South
Korea and the European Union and you're
known to be a supporter of NAFTA as well
what are the best ways to promote the
benefits of free trade in an
increasingly anti-trade global political
environment sure we might be a bit
surprised by my answer on this I'm
actually writing a book on this very
subject on the rise of populism what's
driving in and particularly how
conservatives should respond first of
all just on the record when we came to
office when my government came to office
in 2006 spite of the fact that Canada is
one of the most open economies in the
world we had free trade agreements with
only five countries and when I left we
had concluded negotiations with 51 and
now all are in the process of being are
either implemented or being implemented
and that by the way that was another
thing you know in an era where there's
increasing resistance to trade that was
another thing we did with overwhelming
public support none of those trade
remnants were unpopular so why is that
and look what I tell policymakers
particularly the conservative
policymakers who form the International
Democrat union what I tell them is it is
not a simple matter of being for free
trade
I understand David Ricardo I understand
the basic theories of free trade but
that's not good enough
a trade deal is a large commercial deal
this is actually to some degree where I
agree with what President Trump is
saying you actually have to know what
you're doing when you sign such a deal
you can't do it on the basis of theory
or the basis of simply bureaucratic
internal consultations and negotiations
when we did trade deals
we established comprehensive
consultations with every single major
sector of Canadian society we understood
at the bargaining table what the
interests of our economy actually were
we understood both what interests we
needed to advance in terms of trade we
also want understood what interests we
needed to protect because protection is
part of your responsibility as a
government when those are your interests
so we understood what the interests are
obviously we would lean to opening up
markets and we ultimately understood
what kind of concessions we couldn't
could not make where we could make gains
and where we could not make gains and
particularly the additional factor we
had in place is when we dealt with
larger entities like the European Union
we had to know what they wanted and we
spent a lot of time finding that out so
you know it comes down to treating it as
a serious commercial deal understanding
all of the periods and commas and making
a good deal for the country and is it
possible you know president Trump
doesn't say it doesn't click say he's a
protectionism protectionist maybe is he
says he's for good deals and not bad
deals is it possible to have a bad trade
deal absolutely and there are many times
I would have walked away from the table
rather than have signed what was on it
there's something else that you said
about about overwhelming public support
though and essentially selling these
deals are getting these deals
last with in your public eye wouldn't
the court of public opinion so is there
a component to this of winning hearts
and not just Minds yeah look I think I
think advantage we start with in Canada
was we had our you know our first free
trade deal
besides Confederation itself our first
free trade deal was the Canada us
agreement concluded in 1987 it became
the focal point of the 1988 federal
election in which the then Progressive
Conservative government was championing
the deal and the opposition the Liberals
and the New Democratic Party were
opposing it and the rhetoric got very
high you know the according to the
opposition signing of the free trade
deal would devastate multiple Canadian
industries basically hollow out the
Canadian economy and eventually would
you lose our independence and become the
51st state of the United States this was
literally in fact a famous ad from that
campaign almost no one here is old
enough to know this famous ad from that
campaign was to negotiators sitting at a
table and the American says let's just
let's just I think we've got a deal if
we just kind of take out this one line
and you go back and the line was the
border so but the the government won the
election principally on a split vote of
the opposition they won the election and
they passed the deal and not only did
none of the things the opposition
predicted come true but frankly the deal
in its economic performance and the
eventual NAFTA exceeded all forecasts in
terms of its encouragement of trade and
economic growth so you have that
backdrop that Canada is a trading
country and with that experience no one
really believes kind of hysteria about
trade but look I will tell you this we
didn't operate on that alone I talked
about the kind of comprehensive
consultations we ran and I can tell you
this when I got up in front of the
Canadian public whether it was in
Brussels or somewhere in Canada to TPP
in the case to announce in the election
to announce a major trade agreement when
I got up in front of people and then
every group in the country every
interest group every sector would put
out its release saying they were for the
deal against the deal or mixed feelings
I knew in advance what every single
interest group of the country was going
to say we were not guessing about public
opinion we knew exactly so yeah you win
hearts and minds but yeah actually it's
it's it's not this is not an issue these
are people's vested economic interests
you cannot treat them as a strictly a
philosophical battle it is about really
understanding where the rubber meets the
road and where people will see they gain
or lose when it comes to interests would
love to talk a little bit now about
foreign policy interests and
specifically one example of your
leadership it's I'll lay out the
scenario first it's November of 2014
you're at the g20 summit in Australia
and Vladimir Putin comes up to you to
shake your hand you accept the handshake
reluctantly and you say to him you need
to get out of Ukraine you take us
through what were your head in that
moment sure well I'll tell you more of
the story first of all like like so many
leaders I had gave given Vladimir Putin
the benefit of the doubt when I first
came to office you know he had come to
power in Russia after a terrible decade
where the country literally fell apart
and the economic and social indicators
for Russia from that period or some of
the worst Frank it wasn't just the
political collapse some of the worst
social and economic collapse any major
country's ever seen and so he came to
power to reestablish to order seem to be
you know a strong leader so people gave
him the benefit that at first I gave him
the benefit there at a couple of years
and and increasingly was obvious to me
that he was not and never gonna be a
friend and we can talk about that if you
want but frankly I became in private
meetings increasingly blunt with mr.
Putin unlike some of my international
colleagues in fact I think I became kind
of the bad
bad cop good cop at some of our
international forums so Vladimir Putin
was not unaware of my views and then of
course in and I had been actually even a
year or two before the invasion of
Crimea I had been advocating for his
removal from the g8 not very subtly
certainly not subtly in private and not
even that subtly in public and so he
invades Crimea and eastern Ukraine and
it was really my first meeting with mr.
Putin since that period I let me just
tell you about of the backdrop what
happens at international conferences you
see these things you would not believe
how much time you spent or you spend
arriving at International summary there
is an order in which you arrive it's all
how much by protocol and you all kind of
drive up one at a time and you assemble
in a room behind before the conference
begins you come out and arrive again on
this stage it takes like two or three
hours to arrive so anyway I'd gone
through and I was they were doing the
backwards order the most junior to the
most senior and Prime Minister's no
matter how long you're in office are
always considered junior to presidents
so I had already arrived in the room
backstage with most of the leaders Putin
would have been near the end of the
arrivals and it was interesting because
I tell the story for a bunch of reasons
I'm so I'm in the room I'm at one end
mr. Putin comes in and everybody's
greeting him and slapping him on the
back and all the things we do at these
things that we lives yeah we know we
know all these people you know you get
you get quite comfortable with these
people you get to know them after time
out of time well anyway Putin comes
around to me and he sticks out his hand
and I I had kind of thought what am I
gonna do or say a Putin Canada's support
for Ukraine was extremely strong
obviously I denounced them privately and
so I said to him I I shook his hand I
said I'll shake your hand Vladimir but I
have only one thing to tell you and that
is get out of Ukraine and he paused
looked at me
taken aback and said to me I'm not in
Ukraine to which I said well that's why
it's a waste of my time to talk to you
and by the way I was just reading Teddy
Roosevelt said and this is so true Teddy
Roosevelt said about the Russians in
1905 he said the most annoying things
about the Russians is they will lie to
you even when they know that you know
they're lying
it's an inexplicable national trait but
anyway so I told I said that to Putin
and reason I tell the story is what's
interesting after that the story got out
by the way because the Russians put the
story out not me I don't know why but
was interesting is all the other leaders
witnessed this exchange and what went
through their heads obviously the ones
who facing the electorate's where Putin
and his actions were not popular all of
a sudden they cease being friendly with
him because they knew if the story got
over Harper was not friendly with them
and we were that would be bad so nobody
was friendly with him for the rest of
the conference and then there were
pictures of him sitting at tables eating
by himself and that sort of thing
and but I look I point that out only
because and it's not that it's not that
symbolic actions are everything but it
is interesting how sometimes simply by
taking a stand you can get people to act
and it seems at this time now especially
knowing what we know that that was quite
courageous and prescient I don't go to
brush on business let's put it that way
how would you handle Putin in today's
world almost four years later well it's
this it's the same thing
look I there's no way of avoiding the
fact that Russia is a major power and
cannot be ignored we brought in a host
of sanctions on Russia in coordination
with the Obama administration and others
we would keep those sanctions in place
and I would continue to minimize contact
with Putin except where it's unavoidable
or necessary to conduct foreign policy
as in Syria for example but I would I
would I would not pretend I'm friends
with them and it's my conviction that
Putin does not want to be our friend I
think there's been so much effort made
by successive Western governments to
have friendly and cooperative
relationship with Putin what is just
they fail to understand is that this is
not Putin's objective Vladimir Putin is
a very donkey Murrow a very strong
leader actually in a very impressive
individual in many ways I don't mean to
demean him he's a very one of the more
impressive leaders I dealt with but
Vladimir Putin carries an enormous chip
on his sole shoulder for the fall of the
Soviet Union he believes that the West
was trying to destroy his country and a
large part of his actions are designed
simply to undermine the West as an end
in itself and that's kind of what he's
made of it's good warning to keep in
mind I'd like to shift a little bit now
to leadership style you know as you rose
to prominence in Canadian politics you
showed that you weren't afraid to take
the gloves off in political scraps a
style that that observers some observers
called decidedly uncontained
what led you to adopt this particular
approach I wanted to win you know I
remember I remember another conservative
leader in a particular province saying
to me before a campaign he was saying
you know Prime Minister I respect you
buy-in of a different style I'm not
going to kind of mix it up I'm not going
to go negative on the opposition I'm
gonna
take the high road I said great I said
there's a word for that is what is
called a losing campaign look at
campaigns a campaign it's they use the
word campaign for a reason it's a combat
and it doesn't mean you should you know
do anything to win but you are making a
contrast with your opponents and you
have to be combative from time to time
and every successful leader is you know
you talk about all the great statesmen
of history I guarantee if you go back
and look at their political records they
were successful combatants now if you're
a conservative the liberal media says
this is terrible and on statesmen like
but the other side does it all the time
so you just got to do it you just got to
face that criticism don't be unfair I
used to say I deliver delivered some
very tough criticisms of my opponents
but I always had one criteria with our
staff which was is the criticism true is
the criticism true don't level a
criticism that's not true that's gonna
backfire on you but if you if you see a
weakness deliver it obviously you have
to deliver your own message as well but
that was a you know that's a that's a
big part of it I think the other part of
it is I like to think the other part of
my success was not just winning
elections but ultimately once you get
there you have to know why you're there
and what it is you're trying to do when
it comes to winning there's there's
winning in the short term and then
there's winning in the long term or
medium to long term you once said about
your former finance and histor Jim
Flaherty and I'm gonna quote as fiercely
partisan as he was Jim was also
genuinely liked and respected by his
opponents that's something in this
business something I am and I envy I
can't even get my friends to like me
humor aside how important do you feel
being liked is to securing your
victories and cementing your legacy well
look I in spite of my joke I actually
think I was widely liked by the people
voted for me in fact but look being
being I'm kind of one of those guys I
think being I'm amazed how many people
go into politics because they want to be
loved it's not really a good occupation
if you want to be loved you know it's
you know III do think there are people
go into politics because they like the
cameras and microphones but they can't
sing or dance I so you know look I I was
not attractive the camera in microphones
I was a bit made up a bit differently
than most politicians but I think it's
important to be respected I think it's
important to be seen as having integrity
but being loved or being liked you know
I think that's secondary I think it's
obviously important that you treat it's
important even that you treat opponents
with respect you could still treat them
with respect while attacking them right
there's difference between attacking
someone on a weakness that's legitimate
versus belittling them and we try and
avoid that but ya know I look I think
it's the key is to be respected
especially in democratic politics and I
say safe here I I don't know anybody who
got into politics to be liked and
succeeded so this there's a question
that falls from this and it's one that
we discuss a lot at business school
about what tact you can take the leader
and it it's do you think that we as
leaders have to make a choice between
being warm and assertive in order to get
the job done well look I would say that
you're you know leadership in the
political arena is a bit different than
leadership in business in the democratic
political arena in the democratic
political arena there are different
leadership styles that are successful
for different people not all leaders of
the say not all approaches are the same
certainly not in politics but I would I
would say that the difference in
politics is no matter how good you are
you are going to have a tremendous
amount of opposition and criticism we
encourage that right I mean this is the
difference between democratic politics
and politics and non democratic
countries is we keep our leaders under
scrutiny and credit
in fact in the parliamentary system
unlike your system the prime minister
who has wields most of the power is not
the head of government I was not the
head of state I'm not you know when I
traveled abroad the Governor General of
Canada is first in diplomatic ranking
not the Prime Minister he is the one who
carries the prestige Abbas office in the
country I'm the Prime Minister I had
most of the head of government power but
I had to be subjected daily to attacks
in the House of Commons we offset the
power we grant somebody by the degree of
scrutiny we put them under your systems
a little bit different but there's still
commonality and that is that's what we
do we don't have you know we don't have
cults of personality in democratic
countries that's that is one of the
hallmarks of an undemocratic society
when a leader is beyond criticism when a
leader embodies the state when the
leader becomes somebody that you
actually have to you know worship for
lack of a better term and so no matter
what style you adopt in public life
you're going to have lots of criticism
there's no way around that look I think
in business there are ways of conducting
yourself that would not expose yourself
to that level of criticism sure there
was one thing that maybe is more common
perhaps between politics and business is
the need to build and utilize power over
time and we have actually have a course
here at Stanford at the business school
called path to power which is all about
how individuals build retain lose power
and organizations
it seems based on your career like you
could teach the course of that any notes
but what are the key lessons that you
have learned about amassing and
retaining power oh look I'm not sure
there's anyone to say there's any one
path I think you know if I look at the
successes I had I would attribute them
to two or three things one of them as I
said earlier was the luck of timing you
know in a couple of times when I became
leader of my party and then when I
merged the parties these things happened
because they happened a particular point
of time and I was rightly I was the
right person position to do it
I didn't plan that I couldn't have
planted I know that there are people
actually think I planned all of this
it couldn't have been planned and so I
just happen to be the right person at
the right time to do those things and
there you know that's life right like a
lot of success in life is luck there's
no way around that starting with where
you're born and when and all those
things you know I think one of the
strengths I had that served me well was
that I had a and people understood me
knew that I had a particular view of
public policy and a vision for where the
country should go a direction for the
country and to the extent they shared
that direction you know they could get
behind it now didn't mean that I didn't
consult regularly and you know frankly I
would say that although I had a clear
direction for the country I've often
said this that very seldom did I take a
policy decision in government that was
not overwhelmingly supported by my party
very seldom
I didn't abuse you know I didn't abuse
the power that I had but you know I did
provide a sense of direction there's
other people leave on live who lead on
different bases some people lead you
know one of my predecessors Brian
Mulroney I would say that he led on the
basis of ability to establish warm
relationships with colleagues and he was
a master at that that was probably his
strength Pierre Trudeau the father the
current Prime Minister was
a really philosophically driven prime
minister and led on a couple of you know
key issues of the day so different
people have different styles mine mine
serve me well I like to think I didn't
abuse it in this sense I could have
wielded a lot more power I think I
probably could still easily be leader on
my party if I wanted to I mean I'm de
facto the founder of my party and I
could have turned the party into
essentially a personal political vehicle
if I'd wanted but that was not my goal
my goal in political life I'm driven by
my political conservatism my goal in
life was not just the win an election
and govern my goal was to establish a
long term conservative institutional
force that would be a long-term
contender for power in government and so
I was determined to establish an
institutional organization that would
outlive me and outlive and and then
would not need me down the road so I did
things very different than if I'd simply
wanted to amass power at all cost
Munir quest to establish that long term
conservative institutional platform when
the luck ran out and you were just left
with decisions to make you probably had
to make some choices that felt
impossible did you ever make any
decisions that you wish you had made
differently oh yeah but I never say what
those were well look I would I would say
a couple of things obviously there there
are all kinds of things you would do
different more important in a public
policy sense did I make decisions that
that I didn't want to make at the time
that's the more important thing that I
really wasn't comfortable with them at
the time the answer is yes you know as
the leader of a party as somebody
dealing with political reality from time
to time I had to make decisions that
would not have been my first choice
that said I don't think on any really
big thing that I ever find myself making
a decision I was fundamentally
uncomfortable with I may not have been
my optimal decision but if I really
thought it was the wrong
decision a bad decision as opposed to a
non-optimal decision I would be pretty
reluctant to take it one last question
before we shift to questions from the
audience another former Finance Minister
Joe Oliver said that one thing the media
did not betray enough in the press that
is just one thing well one of the things
he felt anyways was was your passion and
pride for Canada could you talk a little
bit more about where this passion comes
from I don't know where it comes from
you know I to some degree I think it's
the way it should be I mean I'm a I'm a
seventh generation Canadian you know I
tell this story my great-great-great
great-grandfather was settled in
Sackville New Brunswick then part of
Nova Scotia in 1774 the year before the
American Revolution and was the local
leader of the militia for the crown
against the revolutionaries so it goes
back a long way but look I'm I'm a
product of my country I so much of what
I've enjoyed in life is because of my
country I don't think there many
countries in the world where somebody
like me from a modest middle-class
background and a public school education
would have become the leader of their
country a major country I think that
says a lot about the kind of social and
economic opportunity and mobility we
have in Canada I love our country's
history I love our country's geography I
I won't go far as to tell you that I
always loved the weather but you know
it's it's I'm always turning the
temperature down in hotel rooms when I
outside of Canada so I must like it
somewhat you know but I think this is
partly natural what I don't understand
and I say this about the other side I
don't understand the modern I would call
modern elite liberalism that often seems
not to like its country to me being a
nationalist as you know I'm not talking
a nativist or as MFO but being a
nationalist
is something I would have expected from
any leader
star you know if you don't love your
country if you don't if you're not
deeply rooted in it don't love its
people don't love most things about it
why are you leading it in the first
place so to me this is just what you
would expect of someone who aspires to
to be head of government of a country
thank you now we'll open it up to
questions from the audience thanks so
much for being here
my name is Adi an undergrad in math and
computer science
I was curious to hear your thoughts on
the 2008 financial crisis and broadly
how you approached making decisions and
fiscal policy yeah well look obviously
that was a that was an interesting time
for me because I had begun my political
career in a policy sense my number one
focus as a economist an economist whose
specialty is fiscal policy was about
back in the 80s and 90s fixing Canada's
fiscal problems and creating a long-term
structural balance eliminating the debt
problem of course we did that in the 90s
and my first few years in government I
inherited a surplus continued to run a
surplus used it predominantly to reduce
taxes by the way which is I think what a
good conservative would do but I didn't
use it to reverse taxes in a way that
create a structural deficit I wouldn't
cut taxes of a good and pay for it all
of a sudden we have the 2008 financial
crisis people forget I even pledged in
the election campaign that I would not
run a deficit despite the what was
impending recession but what people
forget is like each week it was really
something to be in power at that time
you know from September of 2008 till I
would say January February of 2009 we
literally were in a situation where
economic activity was visibly falling
around the globe every single week and
it was just incredible you'd wake up
every morning with cataclysmic economic
news all around the world
well it became apparent to me and it was
fortunate I the right training I'm not
just the fiscal policy economist my
background is in economic history and
macroeconomic theory and it became very
apparent to me that we were in what I
would was a kind of a theoretical
Keynesian situation but coming to real
life and I concluded it was necessary
for us to run not just allow the budget
to fall into deficit but it became
necessary to run a significant stimulus
program because of the collapse of
economic activity and so we did that but
we also with Minister Flaherty's late
Jim Flaherty finance ministers guidance
we did as soon as we did that we put in
place a program to gradually restore
economic balance which we did over five
years so it was a tough decision by the
way not easy one to get through my
caucus a large percentage of my caucus
did not want us to run a deficit did not
want to run the stimulus program but I
think I was able to convince them
because partly because I was so known as
a fiscal hawk and also because of my
training I was able to convince them
that we were in a situation that
required extraordinary measures but I
assured them ensured Canadians that we
would not ruin the long-term financial
structure of the country and we
ultimately succeeded in that
ernesto silva here i'm a member of the
chilean congress and i'm sorry ernesto
tilba I'm a member of the Chilean
Congress you mentioned that you are
writing a book about how conservatives
should face the rise of populism yeah
could you comment a little bit on that
please yeah I'll do it very quick first
of all you know it's it's interesting to
hear the term populist described today
as it is usually pejoratively and often
pejoratively by conservatives populist
are anti-market anti-trade etc the
Reform Party that I was involved in
founding described itself as a populist
party it was for trade and for markets
it was really a populist party in the
den trade
should've Thatcher and Reagan so
populism is a term that kind of has
different meanings in different contexts
I often think that when you see the term
populist used in the media today it's
used this way we describe outcomes we
like as democracy and outcomes we don't
like as populism so I think there's a
bit of a loaded term there but to the
extent that in the globalization age
that I like to think we as conservatives
brought about globalization free or
trade free markets free or migration
around the world we're now seeing a
backlash to that and I really believe
that a conservatives people who are
students of human experience rather than
just to cry that when we see our own
voters being attracted to that we need
to ask ourselves why and I think in the
age of globalization that way too many
ordinary people are not doing well
enough and when you look at some of the
things the populace complained about in
terms of trade policy or market policy
or immigration policy globalism is a
philosophy I do think that in some cases
well we're on generally the right track
we've pursued policies that haven't
really thought hard about the actual
impacts on ordinary people that's what I
always tried to do I'd say I was not a
blueprint kind of politician I don't
believe in them but I think in a lot of
cases politicians have followed
blueprints and have not been very
conscious of how some market-oriented
policies actually impact people and we
should be making sure we understand what
those impacts are just to give an
example the importation in many Western
countries large-scale importation of of
low-skilled workers at a time when
low-skilled workers are under
technological pressure and their wages
are falling this makes no sense in terms
of the social outcomes it produces
allowing foreign non-residents to buy
significant blocks of residential real
estate and leave it unoccupied in major
urban centers yeah that's an open market
policy but what is the social utility of
that other than
to drive people out of the areas they
live in so I you know I think we really
have to think hard make sure I'm strong
believer and strong believer that in
overtime only market-oriented policies
really create growth but you really have
you know they can take a lot of forms
and you have to pursue them in ways that
are getting good outcomes too many
working middle-class people in Western
countries especially this one by the way
I've simply not been doing very well and
we have to understand why that is and
adapt to those concerns no point you
know we're conservatives no point
screaming no point you know if voters go
a different way no point telling them
they're wrong in democracy the voters
are always right so if our voters are
telling us we're off track we better
listen to what those messages are and
figure out which messages are right and
which messages are wrong my name is Amy
I'm a finance PhD student here at the
GSB I'm also a proud Canadian who has
been in the United States since college
almost a decade ago over this period of
time I sense a growing divide between
the coastal elite and the rest of
America as you travel around Canada do
you sense the same trend of polarize
polarization the answer to that is no
Canada has not had the kind of political
polarization or this modern
manifestation of more extreme populism
that we've seen in the United States and
other parts of the world and the reason
for that is I like to think is really
rather simple it's that you know Canada
in Canada middle and working class
people have had fairly steady income
growth even through the global financial
crisis and so I think that that I think
there may be other factors driving the
polarization I'm but you know what
Canada is not immune if we practice a
series of bad economic policies over a
long enough period of time and people
start to feel dispossessed or ignored by
the political system we could get the
same thing in Canada but we don't we
don't have it today we have had
political change we have political
debate
have parties with different views but
it's not a deeply rooted social cleavage
which is what really strikes me here
really strikes me about the United
States is not simply the political
polarization but the degree to which it
actually reflects in my experience the
American public you know I've just tell
you I've told Canadians for a long
period of time my experience george w
bush was president barack obama was
president obviously and now with donald
trump i would say to people if you go
the united states don't kind of give
your opinion of george w bush or barack
obama or a donald trump until you know
what the listener thinks because i
guarantees on one side or the other and
that's just the way the country is here
and I think it's worrisome but I think
underlying yet underlying it is the fact
that tens of millions of Americans who
used to have a good middle-class
lifestyle no longer do and this is a
serious problem that has got to be fixed
so I wanted to wrap with the last
question and draw on a few things that
you just talked about with us today
you've mentioned some some pretty
technocratic terms you know social
utility and productivity these are the
terms of somebody who's clearly deeply
versed in economic policy I wanted to
step back though and ask about the
emotional aspect of leadership and
specifically the ways in which you unite
people through the emotional appeal of
your of your leadership and a lot of
these themes that you've spoken about
with conservatism you know are still
getting out what ultimately the voters
want and what's best for them how do you
ensure that they connect emotionally to
your policy views and to ultimately what
conservatism is trying to do well look
that's a good question and I'm not going
to get up and claim it was one of my
strengths it's not a strength of
conservatism by the way you know I I
think if you look at you know other
movements whether they be on the right
or on the left
modern liberalism socialism nationalism
pop you know modern right-wing populism
these are at their heart more
essentially emotional appeals I do think
not that we
you know we have to connect to people
where they live and they live
emotionally but I honestly think that
people tend and I say to conservative
leaders people tend to turn to
conservatives when they're really deeply
worried and they want sensible solutions
and when they want something beyond the
mere emotional they want to be convinced
that there's somebody actually knows
what they're doing and that will work
and so well I think it's important to
connect emotionally and we often don't
do a good enough job of that
I think conservatism can never be a
purely emotional political philosophy
the way so many others are ladies and
gentlemen please put your hands together
for mr. funders
[Applause]
[Music]
you